ice spice's brother is getting trolled
on his high school football field and
opponents are using ice spice's lyrics
to do so Joey gone is a Star Quarterback
for Iona Prep and he sended an interview
with complex sports that when he goes up
against Defenders and gets sacked is
when he usually hears some ice Bice
chatter he said a defensive end sacked
him once and said you thought I was
feeling you referencing one of his
sister's song lyrics gastone said he
loves the competitiveness and it's all
love he even walked onto the field
during the semi-finals of the playoffs
and heard his student section start a
wheel of ice spice chant